We'll start with protocol definitions.
Here's a protocol I'm calling Souschef.
Much like a class or struct definition,
it begins with the word protocol,
followed by the protocol name,
and then in between curly braces we
define its properties and methods.
This protocol has no properties and
two methods.
You can see that the methods
aren't implemented here,
that's left up to the conforming type.
Here, we just have a list of method
signatures indicating parameters and
return types.
The next step is for a class, struct,
or enum to adopt the protocol.
And the code looks like this.
Here, we have a class called Roommate.
We want the Roommate class to
adopt the Souschef protocol, so
an instance of the Roommate
class can help make dinner.
To adopt the protocol,
we just type a colon after the class
name and then the name of the protocol.
And what does the compiler
have to say here?
Type Roommate does not
conform to protocol Souschef.
This message is letting us know that we
still need to implement the methods in
the protocol.
Remember, placing the name Souschef here
is akin to the class signing a contract
to implement the methods listed
by the Souschef protocol.
We still need to fulfill our contract.
So here in the Roommate class, we need
to conform to the Souschef protocol,
meaning we need to write implementations
for the chop and rinse methods.
They will each take in
a vegetable string and
return a string indicating that their
sous chef duties have been fulfilled.
Soon enough, you'll be writing
protocols for your own custom classes.
Still, more often than not, you'll be
implementing protocols written by Apple.
Let's practice the syntax we
just learned on a protocol from
the Swift standard library.
This protocol is called Equitable.
We can Cmd+click on the protocol
name to see its definition.
There's a lot of commenting here, but
the protocol actually
only has this one method.
It takes in two values,
the left-hand side in the right-hand
side of an equality and
returns a bool indicating whether
the two values are equal.
In other words, with this method
in the equitable protocol
we can define what it takes for
two instances of a class to be equal.
As you just saw, to adopt the protocol,
we just type equitable
here after the class name.
To conform to the protocol,
we need to implement this function which
is named with just the equal operator.
And we'll say that two
instances of the class Roommate
are only equal if they have the same
name and the same bool value for hungry.
You'll notice that I've implemented
this function outside of the class.
That's because operators
are global functions.
And now,
we can test whether two instances of
the Roommate class are equal.